le café du matin qui réveille ou celui
qui permet de passer le temps en prison
les quantités sont telles que le canada
va un appel d'offres pour acheter le
café destiné au pénitencier et les
contrats octroyés réserve des surprises
nous les avons trouvés parmi les 500
mille contrats de travaux publics canada
que l'émission enquête a obtenus par la
loi d'accès à l'information
castrés jean christophe hutteau les
autres du chaud café timo une entreprise
de saint léonard est choisi pour
approvisionner les pénitenciers fédéraux
au québec depuis huit ans année après
année
kafi timo est toujours le plus bas
soumissionnaire
hors cac ficci mot appartient des
membres de la famille caruana liés à la
mafia sicilienne
c'est un peu ce que vivre ça mais d'un
autre côté je suis surtout inquiet c'est
en compagnie de journalistes andré
cédilot a écrit sur la mafia à l'éclat
caruana contrat est considéré par la
police comme le courtier planétaire en
transport de drogue et blanchiment
d'argent pour le compte de la cosa
nostra en sicile
giovanni caruana et le président de
cafés tim howes jusqu'en 2012 date de
son décès cela faisait déjà cinq ans que
des milliers de détenus du vaisseau qui
fit giovanni caruana c'est pas n'importe
qui giovanni caruana c'est un homme
d'honneur
il était chef de canton dans la province
d'agrigente en sicile avant de s'amener
au brésil et au venezuela et à montréal
il était au quart d'heure du conflit qui
a conduit à l'assassinât de paolo violi
en 70e
fin des années 90 l'italie enquête sur
les tonnes de drogue que le clan caruana
contraire en importe entre autres caché
dans du café pour en camoufler l'odeur
elle condamne giovanni caruana in
abstentia pour association à la mafia et
demande au canada de l'extrader ce qui
n'a pas été fait
au décès du père café philo continue à
vendre son café au pénitencier
un des fils joseph est le vice président
nous sommes allé lui demander comment il
avait obtenu les contrats alors qu'il a
déjà été condamné pour trafic d'héroïne
en 1982 puis j'ai été pardonné et
j'étais faites m'ont pas plu ou alors
vous avez fait votre pensée oui quand j
y ai fait sept ans et est ce qu'ils ont
posé des questions sur votre pass
ces travaux publics canada refuse de
nous accorder une entrevue dans un
courriel
le ministère indique que cette commande
ne comporte aucune exigence relative à
la sécurité
comme toujours on fait de l'aveuglément
volontaire on ne comprend pas on ne veut
pas comprendre comment fonctionne la
mafia comment l'esprit de la matière
comment la passion est patiente comment
la mafia va vont infiltrer les
entreprises et par le pari que chez nos
institutions publiques de superstition à
la fin des années 90 une enquête
internationale cible le clan caruana
contrat qui est établie au venezuela au
brésil et au canada à montréal
les enquêteurs suivent la piste de
gerlando caruana un cousin joseph leur
conversation téléphonique que sont
écoutés nous avons les résumés la police
enquête à ce moment là sur l'importation
de 200 kg de cocaïne
le langage est codé ça fait des mois
qu'ils ont eu une belle conversation de
prête-noms aussi que pour qu'ils courent
pour camoufler des opérations don
illégal des mafieux impliqué dans des
villas des dents
et transaction le géant je n'ai jamais
acheté de voix requis tant pis pour ça
pourquoi ce besoin d'un des joueurs mais
c'est dans les conversations
téléphoniques en 2000 des cousins de
joseph dont gerlando sont condamnés à de
très longues peines d'emprisonnement
dans cette opération joseph lui n'est
pas accusé mais la police le fish comme
membres du crime organisé
revenons à café timo notre visite nous
montre que la livraison de café se fait
par servais ceux de courrier
l'entreprise ne semble pas avoir de
camions l intéressant lorsqu'on sait que
le service correctionnel s'inquiète de
la sécurité lors de la livraison
uniquement
ainsi le contrat avec café chimie
indique que le canada peut exiger une
enquête sécuritaire en ce qui concerne
les personnes assurant la livraison
les services correctionnels refus de
nous accorder une entrevue au montant
c'est un privilège d'avoir des
contraventions c'est pas une obligation
de désamour de donner au privé les
années
donc est ce privilège là il faudrait
quand même qu'ils sont cautionnés par
une certaine morale est ce normal que le
service correctionnel face à faire avec
une famille disons aussi connu j'ai fini
de la congrégation
mais nous ici c'est le plus bas
soumissionnaire alors je vous pose la
question est ce normal que les
pénitenciers canadiens achètent du café
alors que la compagnie appartient à des
gens qui sont très clairement liens avec
la mafia
écoutez vous avez vu les réponses
laconiques j'ai eu la part du
gouvernement et puis les réponses aux
différentes selon as qui vous la poser
parce qu'il ya des gens qui vont vous
dire que pardon c'est ça c'est pour
effacer le passé permettre à quelqu'un
de se refaire une vie il y en a d'autres
qui ont enquêté sur le crime organisé
sur la mafia qui connaît sa mafia qui
vont vous dire que le plan country rock
caruana est encore actif et que c'est
bien mal connaître la mafia d'imaginer
que la cei c'est d'investir dans
l'économie légitime
et puis je retient votre attention
patrice sur le fait que l'algérie a
réagi vivement au budget 2015 2016 en
tant qu y avait beaucoup moins de sommes
qui étaient allouées aux enquêtes sur le
crime organisé
en fait ce sont les sommes qui sont
alloués au dossier sur le terrorisme qui
me guide qui menacent les autres
enquêtes dont celle sur le crime
organisé à cette choix que nous faisons
mais voilà merci à ce reportage sur voir
enfin